Bloom's Taxonomy is a toolbox that
teachers or students can use to classify
and organize learning objectives. It's
most popular version is based on the
cognitive domain and assumes that
learning should be structured from easy
to difficult in the following six steps:
One: remember. Two: understand. Three: apply.
Four: analyze. Five evaluate. Six: create On
the first level we learn to remember.
There is just rote memorization and
recollection of facts without much
understanding, for example if we learn
about lemons we want to remember the
name, shape, color, size and that they are
sour
once we memorise these essentially
meaningless facts we move to the second
level of learning. On level two we learn
to understand. We begin to decode
information and learn that a lemon is
yellow when it's ripe to eat and if we
take a bite that it's really super sour,
we also understand that lemons love
sunshine and that they contain lots of
vitamin C which is a great natural
antioxidant that keeps us healthy. Now as
we really understand a lemon we can work
with it. On the third level we apply what
we know. We've understood that while
lemons are sour they are also a great
provider of vitamin C. To apply this
knowledge in a meaningful way we could
boil a lemon into hot water and add some
honey, then serve this hot lemon to our
sick sister who's in need of treatment.
On the 4th level we learn to analyse,
this involves examining and breaking
down information into components
determining how the parts relate to one
another and finding evidence to support
generalisations. We study the lemon flesh,
examine the skin and look at levels of
vitamins. We conclude that we can eat
everything inside while the skin tastes
bitter and contains traces of toxic
pesticides it ought not to be consumed.
Now we are ready to evaluate, we analyse,
critique and compare. To evaluate our
lemon as a good source of vitamins we
compare it to other sources such as
oranges and supplements. We look at the
following properties: vitamin levels,
affordability, taste and packaging waste.
If we evaluate our thoughts critically
and without bias we learn where the
lemons score high and where others score
higher. Now after we have learned,
understood. applied, analysed and
evaluated, we are ready to create. As we
now really understand lemons also in
comparison to similar things we can
formulate a plan to create our own
natural lemonate. It's now easy to come
up with a cute shop design a good name
and a good slogan: "natural, healthy, yummy"
Bloom's Taxonomy was first created in
1946 by American psychologist Benjamin
Bloom. The revised version from 2001, as
just presented, serves as the backbone of
many teaching philosophies in particular
those that aim towards teaching specific
skills. Each level usually comes with a
clear learning objective that can be
tested. Critics of the taxonomy often
questioned the existence of a sequential
hierarchical link between each level.
What are your thoughts? Please share them
in the comments below
Millions of students from all around the
globe have watched our Sprouts videos
for better learning, thousands of
teachers play them in their classrooms
to start projects, volunteers on YouTube
have translated them to over 25
languages, our mission is to promote
learning by doing in classrooms around
the world. If you are a great explainer
and a passionate teacher and you want to
help us develop outstanding content
contact us, to support our channel with a
donation visit patreon.com slash sprouts